we've heard enough excuses from Hillary
Clinton as to why she didn't win the
White House I didn't think there were
any more left but behold there's another
here's her latest gem you may be the
only presidential candidate since World
War two that actually had to stand up
and say I am a capitalist and you did
did it hurt you probably I mean you know
it's it's hard to know but I mean if
you're in the Iowa caucuses and 41% of
Democrats are socialists or
self-described socialist and I'm asked
are you a capitalist and I say yes but
with appropriate regulation and
appropriate accountability you know that
that probably gets lost and though my
gosh she's a couple I mean all right
well so people like yet another we're
like adding in my past tag yet another
excuse so what's going on here Greg
because I know you get delighted every
time Hillary makes an appearance it's
this one's especially hilarious because
she's right yep a large portion of the
Democratic Party are sniveling
socialists therefore the universal base
income higher taxes guaranteed jobs
identity over the individual but they
weren't voting for Trump she was their
only choice so she should be complaining
and I don't think the Democratic Party
would actually disagree with her on this
they do they are chasing a failed system
we have the most effective political
economics economical system in the
history of the world but the Democrats
are like Sideshow Bob they keep walking
into rakes you know and it's always good
to be they're always gonna move to
socialism and they're always gonna fail
alright that was a good dad at all but I
think we should move this excuse maybe
to number one it actually has some
credence to it so well done well but
it's a lie too it's very instructive
about what's going to happen in 2020
yeah because the ground really shifted
under Hillary Clinton's feet from when
she ran in 2008 to 2016 in 2008 Bernie
Sanders could not have run as an avowed
socialist and won if you think about the
free trade politics of a JFK a Bill
Clinton even a President Obama
everything had changed and
I don't know what they're going to do in
2020 because if the economy is going as
well it's going super well now can that
continue to 2020 probably for a little
while here how are you they going to
make an argument that there should be
something different I think that will be
very difficult but if you look at a
place like Ohio right now is a very
heated gubernatorial race the Bernie
Sanders supporters are out there in
force and you have a state that is
actually pretty turning pretty red and
it's more likely that a Republican will
be able to win both statewide contest
the Senate and the governor's race this
year all right indeed it's interesting
it probably like furiously scribbling at
home to come up with another idea it was
like whoa this tactic is not going to
work but it's true you saw it with just
kind of the groundswell of support Jesse
for Bernie Sanders more progressive
candidates forcing the Democratic Party
as a whole to tack further to the laughs
a more progressive ideology a little bit
of a pinch farm there yeah Democrats
like Bernie because he fights for the
poor and he looks poor that really helps
him with the hair and everything like
that Democrats don't do what when they
run really wealthy candidates if you
look at Gore and Kerry and Hillary you
got to get someone like Bernie that's a
little disheveled and can fight for the
little guy
that's authentic but honestly capitalism
is a dirty word for Democrats they love
socialism but they can't define it when
you ask a Democrat and I do this on the
street where has socialism worked they
can never say whereas it worked in
Venezuela not so much they don't give
you the point of Sweden right so the
point of Sweden okay if Sweden is fine
if you want to be taken care of for the
rest of your life if you want to live a
middle-class life if you start with
nothing in this country you can have a
yacht and Sweden that could never happen
the best part about America is there's
upward mobility and grit and that's
rewarded it's never going to be rewarded
in Sweden and that's why the Democrats
get themselves in trouble because
they're always offering handouts instead
of hand ups like an infomercial you too
can get a yacht no there are some very
good-looking poor people I was poor I
was poor for a long time I'm still more
poor than you just proved your points
all right
really didn't mean that nevertheless the
mom text is going to be a she already
hit me up for a poll I sided and she
wanted the sample size and margin of
error in fact you know you asked your
reciting Rasmussen which is conservative
leading they have almost half of
Americans agreeing that we should have
guaranteed jobs in this country that's
scary I guess I guess they're socialist
but I mean what you have at this moment
in terms of income inequality is a
heightened sense of concern and people
feeling oh I got left behind I'm never
going to catch up by the can't get a
house as good of my parents but the key
here is I remember you guys going after
Hillary Clinton during the campaign for
why doesn't she release her speeches to
Wall Street what's oh so this is part of
the same attack initiated by Bernie
Sanders who came within one percentage
point of tying Hillary Clinton in Iowa
State we're about half of the Democrats
said they are they would our
self-described a socialist and those
numbers are national if you especially
look at Young Democrats but I think
they're confusing socialism with
populism of the Trump Bernie Sanders
style which is really about speaking to
economic needs in a nation where the
opportunity for progress has been
diminished because of income inequality
appoint alright that's it for us now